اولادي مرضوا كلهم معهم زله معويه وكل ما
نفوت الحمام بساني مره لما بفوت الحمام
معي نفرين وابني اخذناه على المستشفى كل
يوم ناخذ على المستشفى ومحلول وع الفاضي
من كثر ما بروح على الحمام وريحه بتقتل في
الحمام لا في ميه منيحه الميه بالمره كمان
بضل يكون الاكل كمانان فيش اكل يعني
للاطفال ياكلوا عايشين على التونه التونه
كمان قتلتهم الجبنه واللبنيه هذه كل ما
بياكل بصير معه اسهل منها بياكل بصير مع
اسهل
منها توفير لحليب للطفل هذا كمان انا من
تل الهواء قالو نا اخلله للشمال بردك مش
امان الشمال بنتي جبتها 15 كيلو صارت 8
كيلو نازله معويه جميع الامراض صار فيها
مش راضيه الطيب لا في علاج ولا في اي شي
في الدنيا القدس مشنا بس كل المسلمين حيصل
فيه مش لفلسطين ومش
لغزه
ه